[موسيقى]
انه مكان التقت فيه اليابسه مع البحر فلم
يفترقا ابدا خليج سومبي بمنطقه بيكاردي
شمال فرنسا طبيعه متفرده تجمع بين اشرطه
رمليه ومستنقعات مالحه تجد بها بعض
الحيوانات ملاذها الامثل انها الفقمات
نجوم هذا الخليج بامتياز للاقتراب من هذه
الثدييات التي يصل وزنها الى 150
كيلوغراما يستعد البعض لخوض هذه المغامره
ليقدم لكم المعلومات بالقرب منك
يمنح اوليفيا لضيوفه فرصه اللقاء بهذا
الحيوان الشرس للغايه لكن لا باس من احاطه
اخيره بحيثيات الرحله
300 متر بيننا وبينها حتى لا نزعجها انها
المسافه الامثل لو سرنا على هذا المسار
لكن لو وجدنا فقمه على الشريط الرملي لن
يكون لدينا خيار سوى المرور فسحه تتطلب
استخداما للعضلات
بعد العلامتين الموجودتين هناك سترون
فقمات مستلقيه على الضفاف الرمليه هذه بعض
الفقمات على هذا الشريط الرملي الاول
اخيرا وبعد تسعه كيلو مترات من التجديف
حان وقت اللقاء لكن لا مجال الافزاعها
[موسيقى]
انها رائعه نراها عن قرب ونوشك ان نلمسها
لا اجد الكلمات المعبره لهذا الاحساسيه
في غضون اربعين سنه اصبحت مستعمره خليج
سوما الاكبر في فرنسا من حيث عدد هذه
الحيوانات المحميه
رغم سيكون متوسط غوصها بين دقيقه الى اربع
دقائق كما قد يصل احيانا الى 30 دقيقه حتى
لا تبتل كثيرا ترفع الراس والزعانف
الخلفيه من خلال اتباع طريقه القوس او
الموز وكي لا تفقد السعرات الحراريه ايضا
خليج صوم طبيعه بريه ذات تنوع بيولوجي
هائل لطالما ابهرت السائحين بها كل سنه
يزورها 200 الف شخص
اكتشفون جمالها من خلال المشي او على اظهر
الخيول
او على متن قطار بخاري من الزمن الجميل
هذا الخليج هو ايضا الفضاء الامثل لغنى
كما يلقبونها هنا سبعه وستون عاما تمارس
الصيد على رجليها ووفق هذه الطريقه منذ
كانت طفله صغيره
دائما لرؤيه هذه البقع الفاتحه
توجد الاصناف اصداف بحريه او قشريات تمتاز
بها هذه المنطقه
انها اصداف جميله لكنها ليست كثيره اين
تسكن بالضبط لا ادري يجب تذوقها
لدى الصياد الحق في جمع خمسه كيلوغرامات
من الاصناف في اليوم صيد يتوجه بعد ذلك
الى مطاعم هذا الخليج هذا الخليج استثنائي
في جميع احواله ثري ومتنوع وجميل في كل
الفصول
[موسيقى]
ثروه هائله يستفيد منها كذلك مربو المواشي
في خليج سون
بعده اجيال تفرغت عائله ريجيس ودوني
لتربيه الخرفان ضمن هذه المساحه الممتده
على 400 هكتار من المروج المالحه هذا ما
يصنع شهره خرفان خارج الصوم المستنقعات
المالحه انها تتغذى على الاعشاب التي تنبت
على المياه المالحه والمغموسه فيها
يجب ان ترعى هذه الخرفان هنا لمده 75 يوما
على الاقل وتتغذى فقط على النباتات
البحريه خاصيه معترف بها من خلال حمايه
تسميه المنشا
اتفاق حمايه تسميه المنشا اعترف بجهودنا
وجهود ابائنا والمشوار الطويل الذي امضوه
ثم ان هذه الخرفان ترعى على النباتات
الموجوده هنا وتشرب احيانا من المياه
المالحه نجد نتاج ذلك كله في اطباقنا
وطعامنا
لاكتشاف الكنوز الاخرى في خليج صوم علينا
ان نرفع اعيننا قليلا الى السماء
هذه المنطقه تعد بمثابه جنه للطيور
المهاجره وايضا لمئات الانواع الاخرى
المحليه
التي يعرفها جيدا كل من جون وجوني
انني انادي على طائر الكولفينش انه طائر
ذو تغريد حزين نوعا ما ليس بارعا تماما
لكنه طائر جميل جدا الرجلان مولان بعالم
الطيور شغوفان بها يقلدان زقزقتها على
اكمل وجه
يحدد كل ذكر صغير منطقته الصغيره التي
يغرد فيها لدى الطيور ايضا صراخ يشبه
سفارات الانذار وصراخ للتواصل فيما بينها
وصراخ للتعريف بموضعها المحدد
الشيء الجميل في الغناء مثل الطائر هو انك
تصبح غير مرئي تماما بمعنى اننا نلج عوالم
هذه الطبيعه ونتماها فيها بشكل كلي حتى
نصبح شيئا منها فيقبل الطائر في غضون ربع
ساعه الى 30 دقيقه بوجودنا الى جانبه
من منا لا يرغب في الغوص في عوالم الطبيعه
والابحار في هذه الفضاءات الواسعه خليج
الصوم يمنحون ذلك بكل متعه الممكنه محميه
طبيعيه استثنائيه ذات مساحه 70 كم مربعا
تجعل منها واحده من اجمل الخلجان في
العالم